i was raised by
a mother who was a teacher of social
work in the 1970s who actually taught a
course called racism 101. my mother
taught me
what is today the woke line on how race
works and the things that she taught me
were correct and i have to this day
never voted republican i am a democrat i
am a liberal i always say i am a black
liberal of about 1960. but i found as i
came of age that as i analyzed the
socio-political things happening around
me that concerned race
that i didn't agree with what was
supposed to be the default kinds of
assumptions and i found that my
assumptions which i think would have you
know endeared me thoroughly to the naacp
in 1960 were considered
repulsive
inappropriate naive or conservative
[Music]
hello everyone i'm pleased today to have
with me professor dr john mcwhorter who
teaches linguistics american studies and
music history at columbia university is
contributing editor at the atlantic
magazine and hosts the language podca
cast lexicon valley he's the author of
over 20 books that's a lot of books some
on language and some on race most
recently the best selling nine nasty
words which was released in early 2021
and because one book a year isn't enough
he's coming out with a new one called
woke racism how a new religion is
betraying black america that should
cause a lot of trouble
that's out october 26th he has produced
five courses on language for the great
courses series and appears regularly
with glenn lowry in a podcast about race
issues the glenn show
i first encountered dr mcwhorter at an
aspen ideas festival gathering in 2018
was being interviewed with barry weiss
and afterwards he asked me a rather
difficult question
i'm very pleased to have you coming to
agree to talk to me today and i'm very
much looking forward to our conversation
me too jordan
so i'm going to start by revealing my
ignorance uh what i don't know about
linguistics could fill a lot more books
than you've written even though you've
written many and so i'm curious about
why why
if you could provide the watchers and
listeners with a description of the
field and its relevance and and also
perhaps why you got interested in it
attracted by it's enough to devote your
life to it
linguistics is a cover term for an awful
lot of perspectives but it's not about
translation and it's not about learning
how to speak languages it's about
analyzing language as a scientific
object and a lot of it is a lot like
biology and so we analyze how language
changes what are the physiological
processes that allow us to produce
language and allow us to understand it
how is it that children learn language
there's a certain magic that anybody can
perceive and the way it happens with so
little explicit tutelage linguists study
that and there are all sorts of other
applications there is linguistics and
how to teach a computer to understand
and even produce language there is
language and the social sphere language
as part of a culture's anthropology what
probably would surprise many people for
very understandable reasons is that what
i just mentioned is not my main focus i
can talk about those things on tv so to
speak because the general public is very
interested in those things but i'm
actually
a language change language contact nerd
what interests me is why a language is
different now than it was 500 years ago
and what happens when languages come
together and create new languages and
how that process
operates but when you do linguistics in
the media you're expected to be kind of
chief cook and bottle washer and a lot
of what is discussed in the media
bilinguals is what we call
sociolinguistics which is great stuff
they're people who really specialize in
it i'm just a popularizer of that
particular subfield but that's a quick
cook's tour of what linguistics is and
what in the world i'm doing in it and so
what are your thoughts on that
remarkable facility of children to learn
language i read i think it was
russian psychologist vygotsky made a
claim he he had this hypothesis he
called uh zone of proximal development
which is i suppose the psychological
place you are when you're learning
something new and are engrossed by it
something like the idea of flow and
vygotsky said that adults
um naturally
speak to their children at a
comprehension level that slightly
exceeds their current grasp they seem to
do that automatically even though that's
an unbelievably complex thing to do and
that drags children along you know to
further the development of their
language this seems deep and instinctual
and so and what are your thoughts on on
propositions like chomsky's that there's
something like a
a biological mechanism a specialized
biological mechanism that underlies our
ability to to learn language and to
produce it is is that also under your
purview um i wouldn't call it under my
purview but i find it very interesting
to watch kind of like you rubber neck at
a car accident the idea that there is a
universal grammar that we're born with
and that underlies all languages is
utterly fascinating only a true genius
such as chomsky could have come up with
it but the odd thing is that when you
actually try to find what these
universal grammar specifications are
they could plausibly be encoded in our
genes and be subject to natural
selection frankly since the 1960s i
think most people who practice that way
of looking at things would be hard put
to tell those who aren't in the club
what has been discovered what we know
now that we didn't know then what would
be useful for people in other fields to
know i find it to be a subfield of true
geniuses
treading
water and a lot of them would not want
to hear that and they're going to say
that i don't know enough about it to say
it but you know frankly i think i do
because i pay a lot more attention to
what they do than many people might
think and i'm always wishing that more
would come out of it than does and so i
don't think it's that there is a
grammar tree of some sort even if
encoded in some abstract way that people
are born with the evidence of that
wonderful notion simply hasn't been
borne out but it's obvious that there is
some sort of genetic specification for
the acquisition of and the use of
language because if there weren't one we
wouldn't be the only species who do it
there's clearly something but i hate to
say
whatever it is is much less interesting
than there being this very intricate and
suspiciously computer science like
universal grammar in our brains now
vygotsky is always very interesting and
what he's getting at is that humans
learn to talk when people around them
are chattering and chattering away in
such a way that for example an adult
learner of the language finds absolutely
confounding you just listen to this
stream of things going by even if you've
been carefully instructed in the
language it's that grand nexus of
frustration and so certainly acquisition
is not teaching children word by word by
word but acquisition is also not
children filling out some sort of
sentence parsing grammar that they were
born with it's so it's something that's
much less
precise than that nevertheless what's
amazing is how universally it works you
know all cognitively normal human beings
learn to speak
fluidly fluently idiomatically and
without effort obviously that's
programmed in some way well you see one
of the things that's quite remarkable if
you look at people who are quite
intellectually impaired so people who
suffer from down syndrome for example
they also pick up language
extraordinarily well and that's very
remarkable so
it's really something there are autistic
kids have trouble with language and
autism especially in its more profound
forms is an extremely serious
neurological condition but it's really
is remarkable that something as
cognitively demanding as language and
specialized to human beings as it is is
is so deeply embedded in us that even
intellectual impairment doesn't in many
cases doesn't interfere with its
acquisitions yeah it's amazing it's
clearly localized in certain ways and
chomskyans have talked about a language
organ and i don't think they necessarily
mean that it's in any one place but it's
clear that there are certain parts of
the brain where language is generated
that where language ends up even if
those parts of the brain didn't evolve
for that purpose and yeah they can be
doing their job even if the person is
quite impaired cognitively which shows
that language is a thing in some way the
question is exactly what that thing is i
think linguists are getting closer to
that now than they ever have because
we're learning more i wonder i have
another scientific question i guess is
essentially is
one of the psychologists that i had the
good fortune to know at harvard whose
name i unfortunately forget was a social
psychologist very interested in the idea
of basic level categorization which was
a concept i hadn't come across and one
of the things he told me and had worked
on was the notion that
objects in the world nameable objects in
the world pop out at us at a certain
level of resolution so for example a
child will learn the very short word cat
which is a pointer to an individual
animal rather than the more generic
species level
what would you say perception and i
wonder if
the
grammar of language in some sense is
that that chomsky was searching for is
some sense a secondary consequence of
something more like a perceptual grammar
because you know one of the things ai
researchers have uh been confounded by
since the early 60s is the fact that the
world is very very difficult to perceive
much more difficult to perceive than we
thought and yet it arrays itself in
front of us in all of these nameable and
graspable objects and and the and and
and
so maybe the grammar is is embedded the
linguistic grammar is embedded in the
act of perception in some sense and then
there's a linguistic scaffold on top of
that i don't know if that's a you know
an absurd idea but of course there is
labeling for one thing just the fact
that after a while a child learns that
cat is not just the cat in the house but
has this concept of cat to which you
apply the label cat that's something
that human language does to an extent
that's unprecedented anywhere in the
animal kingdom there's a quantum leap
but then what you're saying seems to be
true if my money were on it i would say
that one universal perceptual
specification that there might actually
be genetically set in our brains is a
difference between roughly nouns verbs
and qualities what we call adjectives
and so there's some things that are more
likely to be labeled by a language as
nouns like a cat there's not going to be
a language that has a verb that is to be
like a cat or you know to per etc it's
going to be a cat and there's certain
things that are more likely to be
encoded as actions and there's certain
things that are more likely to be
encoded as qualities such as colors
those three things are the bedrocks now
once you get to prepositions
and adverbs and prefixes versus suffixes
all of that is up for grabs those things
tend to be epiphenomenal upon the very
basics but yes a universal grammar
probably does entail i think all
linguists think there's a difference
between nouns and verbs some very few
languages seem to contravene that
they're the exceptions to prove the rule
and then there's also qualities and then
beyond that there are many different
schools of thought and you think that's
fundamentally a separation be
between something like things and
actions yeah yeah that seems to be one
of the very basic things right down to
certain brain structures that seem to be
sensitive to it there's a difference
between an action and a thing and the
brain seems to be ready for that that
might have something to do with what we
might call a you a ug a universal
grammar
so now yeah i read and it was on
wikipedia so that's another indication
of my ignorance that you're also known
yeah well fair enough you know if you
need to get informed about something
quick quick that's a great source yes
definitely and and and isn't that
fantastic for all of us that you're also
known as a critic of the superior warf
hypothesis which is really not their
hypothesis at all but it has come to be
known by their names nonetheless and
that hypothesis correct me if i'm wrong
is in its strong form at least the
notion that language structures thought
to such a degree that
speakers of different languages have
qualitatively different thoughts in some
sense and that isn't something that sits
particularly well for you and i think
there are also some political and
practical implications of that that
belief and also the criticism of it is
is any of that off base or
no that's quite on base um
the idea that the language that you
speak gives you a certain
pair of glasses that you see the world
through is very very attractive i
remember learning it when i was an
undergraduate about the hopi native
americans and it's something that you
want to be true but the evidence just
doesn't support it if you look at it in
terms of lots of languages and what the
implications of this would be and so
certainly language does influence
thought in certain ways it's been shown
for example in in russian it's hard for
us to even imagine this unless we're
russian there's no word for blue they
have a word for dark blue they have a
word for light blue there is no word for
just blue and it turns out that if you
subject them to a highly artificial
experiment you can show that russians do
have a glimmer more sensitivity to the
difference between dark and light blue
than either you or i do and the only
reason for that would have to be the
language it's not something about
russian culture and the color blue there
are many things like that that are
fascinating themselves but the way it's
shared with the public makes it seem as
if you learn italian you're seeing the
world in an italian way because of the
way the grammar works because of the way
the vocabulary
um chops up the world and the problem
with that is that there are many
languages that are very very busy that
mark every little jot and tittle of
existence and they tend to be spoken by
small indigenous groups it's very easy
to see those small indigenous groups and
to say look at how sophisticated their
language is they're picking up on every
little sparkle of experience in a way
that say english which is a relatively
telegraphic language compared to those
doesn't but the problem is then you have
to look at languages like mandarin
chinese which is much more telegraphic
than english in many ways if you apply
the grand old media warfian perspective
to a language like mandarin chinese the
chinese end up looking kind of dim
because the language marks so little
nobody wants it to go that way there was
one unfortunate psychologist who
actually tried to go that way quite
innocently and is still being burned in
effigy today and he wrote the article
during the reagan administration because
the truth is that if your language
doesn't have a whole lot in it if your
language has a whole lot in it or
somewhere in between the evidence is
that all human beings think in basically
the same way except for these tiny
shades of difference that a psychology
experiment can breeze out but that's not
life itself and so i think that people
end up using warfianism as a way to be a
westerner who shows that they understand
that non-westerners are cognitively
sophisticated which is great but the
problem is the same thing ends up
insulting half of the world's people
okay so you touched on the political
ramifications of the hypothesis well it
seems in some sense a naive biologically
naive hypothesis because i mean we we've
only been speaking evolutionarily
speaking for perhaps a couple of million
years which is a long time but it's not
that long given our 60 million year
mammalian heritage let's say and and all
and everything that came before that
upon which our perceptual capabilities
have been predicated and so the idea
that language could affect something as
basic let's say as color perception
seems to me to be on the face of it
quite observed i mean i'm pretty
convinced by the arguments for example
that our capacity to distinguish between
green and red is a consequence of our
ancestry as fruit eating primates
essentially yeah yes exactly and you
can't mess around with something that
deep by
painting a surface of linguistic ability
over the top of it at least that's how
it seems to me yeah i think that's
correct
and we all face in many ways regardless
of where we are the same sorts of
problems we have to get along with
others we have to eat we have to uh uh
quell our territory let's say and so
there's a lot more that unites us
perceptually and cognitively than there
is that divides us there is and if you
really look at different languages you
see that you have to celebrate what
unites us rather than what divides us on
the pain of being really anti-scientific
there are languages of new guinea for
example where there doesn't happen to be
a difference between eating drinking and
smoking in terms of the language they
have a word that we would translate
roughly as ingest and they use it for
all those things based on the warfian
analysis they're not as sensitive to the
difference between eating and drinking
and smoking something as we are and so
you end up implying that they're kind of
coarse or that they're kind of crude and
if you look at the group themselves they
are as interested in food and varieties
of foods and ways of cooking as we are
you find that sort of thing over and
over so i wrote the language hoax
because it really started to stick in my
crawl that a lot of people end up
believing this media kind of morphianism
as opposed to academic psychological
warfare ism which is you know
irrefutably true and i was i was bemused
i'm glad that book got around more than
i expected and it seems to now be just
contributing a con side to an argument
there used to be only pro ones of for
the general public so we'll see how it
all pans out
so now when you came to study
linguistics you are also extremely
interested in something else you teach
american studies you also teach music
what else what element of music
um i teach columbia has its core
curriculum where every student has to
take certain courses in the kind of
great books tradition there's a music
course for that everybody goes through
one semester of the masterpieces of
western music so what it really is is
good old-school quote-unquote great
music clapping for credit it teaches you
how to appreciate complex music and the
course as you might imagine is
undergoing some changes in recent years
but it basically takes you from
gregorian chants through
roughly philip glass and many of us
would add jazz at the end so i had been
doing that yeah are you interested in
the musical element of language because
it carries a lot of the emotional weight
right so there's this
there's the just the linguistic end if a
semantic end let's say and you know
perfectly well that you can structure
the same sentence with two different
intonations and mean exactly the
opposite
you do that when you're being ironic and
so
was was your love of music
does that uh what would you say color
your your linguistic theorizing in any
sense or is that a separate endeavor no
the the music loving me is a different
person and to the extent that there is
music as you're putting it in language
that has not happened to be my area the
best person on that is ray
jackendoff who is somebody who actually
has very good proposals against the
chomsky idea too but you know we should
talk to him i know about him i should
talk to him
very important you see the sculpture
behind me this thing here yes yeah i
made that 30 years ago it's called the
meaning of music and it was the
consequence of about a year's meditation
on what it was that music was doing to
us and why we were so attracted it's
such a remarkable phenomenon i have a
weird thing yeah it is a weird it's a
very weird thing and i'll just run my
initial hypothesis by you and so i music
is often regarded as a
non-representational art form
i had a great journalist up to my house
this week rex murphy and he said to me
this was a quote and i don't remember
where he derived it from that all art
aspires to the condition of music i've
heard which is a lovely phrase and
so
what when i started to
think about music i was thinking about
it because it was essentially it was a
engaging experience that was immune from
rational criticism not really so it had
this intrinsic meaning that could not be
subverted by criticism and so it struck
me as something extraordinarily powerful
i started to understand at that time
that
the world in in a really deep sense is
made out of nested patterns and those
patterns we perceive as objects and
actions but but what they are are
patterns in space and time and that
music is actually the most
representative form of of art because it
represents the harmonious interplay of
patterns and then we pattern ourselves
to the music and and find that what
would you say existentially engaging in
a very profound sense anyways that's my
music theory oh with it without a doubt
and the easy version of that is a good
beat because a good beat implies in a
primal sense a certain predictability
and therefore a certain truth i think
you can see in a lot of people a sense
that a good beat in the way you move
your body to it equals a kind of truth
because of the consistency and look how
it unites us yeah and it brings people
together classical music is harder
because it's longer lined and so a lot
of teaching people to appreciate
classical music is to teach them how to
hear it as something other than just
this endless desolatory string of
whatever there's pattern in it too and
you don't really appreciate it unless
you just learn how to breathe and take
in the longer pattern yeah so when you
when you listen to a great classical
piece say a bach concerto or something
like that
how do you have to listen to it multiple
times before you understand it
definitely yes
my rule is you you don't really know it
until you've heard it about seven times
if it's challenging music yeah
yeah okay okay so i didn't know if that
was my i i'm sure there are some musical
super geniuses who don't need that
length of exposure to get it but i don't
get it well maybe two or three with some
people but to me i want to drink it in
you know you know i'd sit with
headphones and
a cd and that's becoming very
old-fashioned but that's the only way
that i can really do it
yeah it's amazing too asa how you expose
yourself to continually to to that
pattern and then you need a certain
degree of familiarity with it so it
still retains some novelty and then you
really fall in love with it and then if
you listen to it a tremendous number of
times in some sense you tend to exhaust
it although the greater the piece of
music in in my experience and maybe this
is a marker for depth and quality and
music the greater the piece of music the
longer it takes to exhaust it
yeah and if it's a really great piece of
music it's never exhausted in my
experience but yes that's true if it's
an okay piece of music on the level of
say a hot dog you'll need 20 21 and then
you've kind of gotten past that and you
look 20 years later and you realize wow
that fell out of the rotation and you
sort of realize why as a parent as
opposed to the things that never fall
out of the rotation because it sounds so
corny but you're always finding
something different or whatever you
initially found the feeling is such a
kick it's such a mind blow that you want
it over and over it becomes church
there's almost a religious story
there's yes there is definitely that and
we could talk about that more too one of
the things i also find absolutely
staggering about music is
how it can have that long lasting and
gripping form
in such an endless variety of genres and
how that greatness and depth can
manifest itself in each of those genres
regardless of what the genre is and
something that's very difficult to
understand something as simple often and
say as country and western music
something like hank williams which is
very straightforward in some ways
still
to me has that quality of
inexhaustibility and it's so
yeah what what amazes me and if i if i
were more profound about these things or
more interested in bringing different
parts of myself together i would study
it it's harmony because melody is one
thing you know melody is a lullaby any
human being is given that rhythm
especially consistent rhythm i'm sure
that we are genetically programmed by
accident to appreciate that harmony is a
funny thing and i think that people who
for one reason or another either
training or temperament or both feel
harmony and get harmony think that all
human beings hear harmony the way they
do no it's a very odd kind of ear and i
find myself wondering what is it about
major and minor and then everything else
and the fact that if you're a music
listener you you associate those things
with certain feelings you often find
that other people don't have the same
feelings about the ones that you do but
yeah it's a weird thing this thing
called music you associate a certain
combination of notes with nostalgia for
me the flatted cysts means it reminds me
of the past why
very interesting things why would it
remind you of anything when it's
something that didn't exist when homo
sapiens emerged fascinating stuff i had
a master's student when i taught at
harvard who did her thesis on the
meaning of music from a biological
perspective and one of the things she
came across and i don't remember whose
thoughts these were was that
deep bass notes remind us of large
animals
and high notes remind us of small
animals this is obviously a part a
partial explanation right obviously and
that
more major tones are more maternal and
comforting and minor tones are more
discordant and reminiscent of emotional
upset something so that feels right
exactly
it's so there's and and it that ties in
in part into the
emotional aspect of language itself and
and
all those things that we pick up and but
yes but then the question is you know we
quote unquote europeans i know it's
weird for me to say that but i think
people understand we hear major and
minor and low and high that way i wonder
if someone an indigenous person who had
never heard music like that before let's
go to irian jaya it's not called that
anymore but the western half
somebody from there i wonder if they
would hear it that way and i can make a
guess the low notes being associated
with the elephant and the high notes
being associated with the hummingbird
that's probably universal because that's
true about language oh ah is big e is
small that's that's true however the
other parts i wonder if all of that is
just arbitrary european stuff that we
pick up you know from starting from
listening to mother goose songs and then
it going on i'm sure this has been
studied and i have not nosed into what
those people were looking at yes
probably someone knows this and we're
just ignorant about it but
so that so so that's that's all
fascinating american studies now you
also were educated in american studies
and you teach american studies so so a
very wide range of teaching interests
and so
tell me about american studies and what
you're teaching and how you got
captivated by it
well you know honestly american studies
to me
was a backdoor thing that i became
passingly interested in in the 80s after
i got my ba because i thought of it as a
way of studying in a systematic way
american popular culture of the late
19th through late 20th centuries which
obsesses me to this day i'm a huge fan
of the movies the radio shows the comic
strips the cartoons the music i you know
i could get along living in 1936
hopefully you know white but living in
1936 and knowing everything that was
going on better than i think many people
could just because i enjoy it's not that
i think 1936 was better but i just like
that stuff and if you do american
studies you get to read books by
historians and philosophers and film
scholars about those things i got a
master's degree in it at nyu at a time
when the program in american studies for
most of the people in it was kind of a
night school and the truth is i sense
where you might very understandably
going which is that i have the masters
in american studies and that informs why
i'm a media commentator about race
issues these days but actually no the
american studies degree i wrote a
master's thesis on scott joplin's opera
treatment and then left that behind and
got into linguistics which had no
relationship to any of that at all
linguistics i found was where i needed
to live as opposed to american studies
where i got to read an awful lot of
great books and i don't regret it i
really enjoyed it but it was really just
a passing phase when i was in my my
early 20s yeah i did i did wonder about
that that relationship and thought that
there might be some connection what is
it about the mid-30s that fascinates you
so much
it first looked good and it was it was a
terrible classist racist sexist time
everybody's smoking cigarettes it's not
that i think that it was somehow better
but if you think about it the 1930s the
fashions the people looked good their
hair looked good the cars looked good
the music hit a really sweet spot in
terms of how a swing band sounded or
even before that an early jazz band
sounded and then there was an awful lot
of great i love
literature the thirties jazz it's the
third is great great era the 40s i kind
of lose it but the 30s was just great
feeling i just love to walk around in it
for seven days and then come back
so all right let me ask you some more
questions so as you developed your
career as an early professor you stopped
being um an assistant professor and you
were at sorry it's just escaped my mind
you where were you first as a professor
cornell or no and then you you went to
the manhattan institute
a conservative think tank i did yeah
okay so okay so obviously that requires
some explanation and so
one of the things i kind of wonder about
maybe is maybe you could shed some light
on is what
what attracted you to conservatism to
the degree that you were attracted and
what is conservatism now if
i've been trying to puzzle this out
psychologically i'm not thinking about
it so much politically because you know
i think there's room for for liberal
thought and for conservative thought and
that the dialogue between those two is
absolutely necessary but but what was it
about conservatism that attracted you
because it's not it's not an obvious
choice
no no it was
really a matter of
an eccentricity about the way race has
been discussed in this country in the
mainstream for a very long time i was
raised by a mother who was a teacher of
social work in the 1970s who actually
taught a course called racism 101. my
mother taught me
what is today the woke line on how race
works and the things that she taught me
were correct and i have to this day
never voted republican i am a democrat i
am a liberal i always say i am a black
liberal of about 1960. but i found as i
came of age
that as i analyzed the socio-political
things happening around me that
concerned race that i didn't agree with
what was supposed to be the default
kinds of assumptions and i found that my
assumptions which i think would have you
know endeared me thoroughly to the naacp
in 1960 were considered
repulsive inappropriate naive or
conservative and so the manhattan
institute i didn't choose it um a lot of
people think that i'm much more
self-directed than i am a think tank
taps you i barely know what a think tank
was but they were doing work on race in
new york city and beyond that i agreed
with and what they were saying was not
black people are all thugs and criminals
and they need to shape up they were
working with for example cory booker who
was the mayor of newark then on prisoner
re-entry programs they were really
trying to do good work for black people
and i didn't see any other think tank
that was doing anything like that and
they summoned me that manhattan
institute is a conservative think tank
but they've always been hospitable to an
extent to democrats i was not the only
one there but understandably while i was
there and i was there for a good long
time a lot of people thought that meant
that i was a conservative republican
whereas it's not that my views if
anybody were
if anybody were to bother to read the
work that i've been doing for what i
hate to say is 20 years now they'd see i
don't disagree with any of the things
that you would consider to be the
liberal orthodoxy except when it comes
to a certain
plangent view of race relations where
the idea is that the proper black thing
to do is to cry weakness rather than
look for solutions i don't get that and
i know that my civil rights forebears
wouldn't have gotten that either but
that's considered a conservative take
only because what's considered the
mainstream take-on race has moved so far
to the radical left okay so let's unpack
that a bit so what i'd like see i kind
of look at
all of the things that you are
discussing in some sense as an outsider
because these are fundamentally american
issues although not entirely and i'm a
canadian and we have our problems but
we don't have exactly the same problems
that you have in the united states and
so i look it's i'm looking at this from
the outside to some degree and trying to
understand it what do you what is this
set of assumptions in more detail
that that
that perturb you and why do you let's
start with that this what is this set of
assumptions about the re uh about race
relations in the us that that perturb
you
well there's one main assumption which
is that it's the job of the
shall we say woke black person to focus
on racist obstacles to black success and
to purport that racism be it social
or systemic is a conclusive obstacle to
general black's success
rather than an impediment that you can
get around and then there's an extension
from that that racism of both of those
kinds is so oppressive that it it's the
defining experience of being a black
person and so it means that if you are a
black person and you're writing you know
be it fiction or non-fiction or opinion
your focus is supposed to be always and
forever racist oppression because if
you're not doing that you're not
authentic and you're dissociating
yourself from blackness in some way and
i find that as a as a montessori kid who
has a lot of interests i've always found
that extremely confining as soon as i
hit adolescence i realize wow i'm
expected to be this
racism-focused person
maintaining a wariness of white socially
that has not been necessary since about
you know five years before i was born
and i think that it is
a cloak that people put on because human
beings seek comfortable cloaks to put on
it becomes a sense of being part of a
tribe but it has a way of departing from
what reality actually necessitates and i
have just not been able to gracefully
allow that sort of thing to define my
life or to pretend to believe in those
things and so when i was around um how
old am i when i start to pop in my early
30s i was at berkeley first was cornell
then was berkeley then was the manhattan
institute and at uc berkeley
there was a dis
the racial preferences were discontinued
the idea was that there were no longer
going to be different standards for
allowing black and latino students to be
admitted than white and asian students
and the way this was talked about
was as if all black people are poor
as if the idea was that you don't change
standards even for people who've grown
up hard when actually most black
students at berkeley by then were very
middle class and the problems were
different and i just couldn't remain
silent i remember the hardest thing for
me was that there would be a white
professor who would come and lean in my
doorway and start
start you know saying all of the usual
pious sorts of things about race that i
don't think truly cohere such as
implying that racism defines my entire
existence and i was expected to just sit
there and nod they really thought that
any black person thought that way and i
thought no you're missing me completely
many many black people feel misread by
whites well i was having a different
version of it and i just got weary of it
and so i very circuitously and not as
deliberately as many people think i
started writing about these things i
thought at first i was just gonna put
out one and a half yelps so that people
would know how i felt and then go on
being a linguist only but for various
reasons that's not what happened and
here i am talking to you about well and
you have this new book
um
walk racism well create well walk racism
and how a new religion is betraying
black america so okay so that's that's
quite the title i mean
i'm sure it was very carefully chosen
and
wikipedia informed me that you're
formally atheistic and so
which may or may not be relevant to our
discussion but it's very interesting to
me that you picked that as part of the
title why
why why do you believe that why why this
emphasis on a new religion and and and
what does that mean exactly
well you know we're at a point
where
the kinds of beliefs that i'm talking
about about black people are no longer
held as an opinion
it's at the point where a certain kind
of person
lives these beliefs in a way that is so
impervious
to any kind of reasonable discussion
that you start to notice that it really
is a matter of
religion
in the sense particularly of abrahamic
religions
rather than opinion and they're all
sorts of so what's what's the difference
between religious belief and mere
opinion in your estimation it is that
many religions require that at a certain
point you suspend disbelief and stop
relying on conventional raciosination
and logic there's a point at which
you're supposed to have faith and
believe in miracles of some sort and
it's at the point where when it comes to
race
there are things that one is supposed to
insist on and believe
regardless of whether they correspond to
reality or even any sense of justice one
in christianity is supposed to be
dedicated to showing that you have faith
in in jesus within the religion that i'm
talking about the cardinal point is that
you show that you know that racism
exists just that you know that it exists
now what you're going to do about it is
irrelevant whether or not what you're
showing actually is racism is irrelevant
the fact is that you knew you were
supposed to be looking for it and only
that imperative as ding-dong as it
sounds explains a lot of the things that
we've seen especially lately there's a
real jump in the rails after summer 2020
but even
before that and it means that a lot of
people look at what goes on with the
race scene in the united states and i
know there's an to an extent there is
that in canada too
you whenever you see these sorts of
things happening and you see brilliant
people making arguments that don't make
any sense and utterly despising those
who disagree with them as if they were
heretics word chosen deliberately it's
because what we're seeing even though
these are people who are usually very
secular in their self-conception it's a
religion this is exactly the kind of
person who
sent galileo into exile a very very long
time ago and the people back then often
didn't think of themselves as religious
it was just considered truth we're faced
with that same kind of thought even if
the word isn't applied and it makes the
reason i'm putting it that way is not
just to annoy people by calling them
religious although i think it will annoy
them and it'll also annoy actual
religious experts who will say that i'm
stepping outside of my lane which i most
definitely am but all of this stuff only
makes sense if you realize that these
people are religious and that they have
to be treated as parishioners and not as
people who are up for an argument i've
had a number of people make the same
case to me recently very profound people
in my estimation so i want to run a few
ideas by and see what you think so
i've thought a long time about
the religious endeavor let's say from
the psychological perspective trying to
unpack it and
it's related in some sense to the idea
of depth and so if you think about
stories
literary stories let's say great works
of literature for that matter and lesser
works we all have this intuition that
some stories are shallow and they might
be entertaining but they're shallow and
some stories are deep and we have the
same sense in music for that matter but
so we have this natural sense of depth
and
part of what that is related to is
something like
place in the axiomatic structure of
propositional thinking
so
something is deep if a lot of other
things you think depend on it and it's
shallow if you can dispense with that
and it doesn't do much to your
underlying cognitive architecture
so
does that seem reasonable so far very
much yeah okay okay and then then i
would say that there's a set of
experiences that are universally human
more or less that occur when our deeper
beliefs are challenged and and that
threatens the way that we construe the
world and our ability to act in it
threatens us with nihilism it threatens
us with chaos it's it's no trivial
matter that happens often when here to
four
um
separated cultures come into contact
with one another definitely so so
worlds can move when that occurs okay so
and then i would say that the set of
emotions that are associated with the
movement of deep beliefs are what we
describe when we describe religious
experience
and this is part of the reason i've had
a number of conversations with
famous atheists and very smart people i
mean
harris for harris for example is
extraordinarily smart person and i'm
familiar with richard dawkins work and
daniel dennett's work these people are
far from foolish but they missed the
point to me to some degree
from speaking even scientifically
speaking because
they treat religion as if it's a set of
abstract propositions about the material
structure of the world and and that's
usually how the argument with religious
people is framed and they're often
foolish enough to accept that initial
framing but there's a lot of
phenomena that fall into the religious
domain that have nothing to do with
propositional
uh propositional truth i mean we have
already had a conversation about music
and music has
often been used
across many cultures for sacred purposes
and part of the reason for that is the
emotional state that it's capable of
invoking which is something like awe at
the deepest level and also its ability
to unite people in harmony let's say and
in dance and all of that and so
there's no escaping the reality of the
religious instinct and so and here's the
point i'm trying to make with all that
to some degree so imagine this think
about this for a second so there's this
statement in the new testament that
we should render unto god what is god's
and see unto caesar what is caesar's and
you couldn't find you'd be hard-pressed
to find a single statement ever uttered
by anyone that had a more remarkable
effect on the development of political
systems because in some non-trivial
manner the idea that state and church
should be separated is justified by that
statement so it's a deadly statement but
i also think it might be true
psychologically and that if we don't
have
an explicit territory marked out
psychologically and socially for the
sacred and so that would be for the
deepest things then what happens is that
things that should not be so deep start
to take on exactly that aspect and i'll
finish this with one one observation
i've been talking with someone i really
admire his name is jonathan paojo and
he's one of the deepest thinkers i've
ever encountered in the religious domain
and he's well-versed in post-modern can
you spell his last name
p-a-g-e-a-u got it okay yeah french
canadian catholic
turned atheist turned russian orthodox
icon carver that's part of this
background anyways
he made a very interesting comment in a
talk i was watching on the weekend about
um
false gods let's say and he talked about
the danger of the idea of inclusivity
when it's elevated to the highest place
or or put in the deepest place let's say
and so
if the purpose of all organizations
becomes radical inclusivity so that's
the uniting factor then the specific
purpose of all those organizations is
instantly threatened
and so part of the problem here is that
what
should be lower in the
hierarchy of values is put in the higher
place
inappropriately
and that produces all sorts of social
catastrophe
so yeah
yeah
the the hard part here is
that it makes you feel like rousseau
was correct
that we'd be better off as small groups
of people say about 200 people living on
the side of a river
and
there is some sort of religion probably
animist but it isn't part of the warp
and wolf of existence because people
have a sense of purpose people have a
sense of warmth people have a sense of
what you might call the sacred in that
it's your group and you know everybody
and you're a brother and you're an uncle
and you're a husband and that's what you
are there's nothing existential that's
going to happen to anybody and i hear
from a couple of people who study
hunter-gatherer groups that that's true
of hunter-gatherers that there's no such
thing as a feeling of anomie when you
are say living in the kalahari but then
once you go further you start to have
this need for something larger which i
fully understand and there are many
people who have said that this new woke
religion and i think it really is one is
something that comes as a replacement
for what would have been ordinary even
if gestural christianity among the same
people in 1955 and i myself i have
religion for me
what people get out of religion i get
out of and this is going to be it's
going to be taken wrong so i have to put
it carefully i get it from musical
theater and i don't mean that i'm really
into liza minnelli you know it's not
grand old ladies and dresses and things
like that it's actually the primal thing
of life being set to music including its
regularities and its harmonies and it
probably culminating in people all doing
things together partly in rhythm and
singing in big harmony to me although i
know that isn't real it seems to give
life a kind of a transcendental
meaning and to me that is so that's
like church okay so that okay so that's
all extremely interesting but but what
one of the things that's most
interesting to me about what you just
said is that
you also felt compelled to interject
that it isn't real now obviously musical
theater is not
okay let's talk about that for a sec
because i've gotten trouble with this
sort of thing when i've been
interrogated let's say about my beliefs
many times in the past so when you say
something like that it begs the question
what do you mean by real
right it's not real it's like well wait
a second and this is something i talked
about with sam harris so here's a here's
a weird thing
are dostoevsky's novels
despite the fact that they're fictional
more real than a purely objective
account of someone's day
or less real
because they're definitely not they
never happened
but the fact that they never happened
doesn't make them not real and so then
we have an annoying channel you mean
because they're channeling something
underlying about the human spirit and
experience or do you mean something else
let's well let's look at it this way so
let's say i i took four remarkable
people and i i uh distilled down their
biography
and then i made a metabiography about
one great person that incorporated and
united all those biographies
would i be closer to the reality of
greatness
obviously we have to decide what reality
is well that's that's the thing
obviously but the thing is it's so
interesting what you said because on one
hand on the one hand you're deeply
gripped by this art artistic and
theatrical representation
and you're unapologetic about that
and and you also think of it as
something at least personally that's
deep and profound and meaningful enough
to to describe it in at least
quasi-religious terms
and then the critical mind comes up and
says yeah but that's not real and i
think well that's like the guy in the
movie tapping the kid on the shoulder
who's watching pinocchio and saying well
you know these are just drawings and
none of this is real it's like well
that's not so obvious that none of it is
real because to some degree it depends
on what you mean by real and and why are
you so sure that the child being gripped
by that isn't more aware of reality than
your rationality
as in it might be part of reality to
experience and consider and even on a
certain level believe in
these idealizations these refractions of
what actually happens in real life that
that is something that deserves a place
within our cognition as we go through
life as people there something is
gripping you obviously because you love
music and then and you and you related
this story
and so on the stage is being portrayed
various modes of being in some
compelling way and music accompanies
that to fill in the context in some
sense that's lacking in the fictional
yes yes yes yes and so i'm not so sure
that it seems to me that
there's more reality in literature in a
very profound sense than there is in the
fractionated view of much of the
scientific enterprise and and for for a
bunch of reasons
it isn't obvious to me at all that
science can truly guide our actions
because we have to make value judgments
but when you watch
a great theatrical performance a
gripping theatrical performance you're
being informed as to how to perceive an
act which is a vital thing to be
informed about and you're doing it
collectively you're doing it to music
and then you know i've watched many
rational cognitive psychologists
essentially especially
kind of dismiss the whole
creative entertainment enterprise which
also gripped you with regard to the 30s
as sort of epic cognitive epiphenomenon
right yes and it's that's not right
that's not only wrong that's really
deeply
backwards it's way way more important
than we think it is and it's more real
than
how else could it unite us if it isn't
real
well what do you mean by real you know
yeah and i would extend it to the rock
concert which i think probably more
people could relate to and i i stand
outside of that because the music forum
doesn't grab me as much but it's clear
that people are feeling the same thing
that i'm talking about and it seems to
be almost a human universal to the point
that to the extent that they're human
groups where music plays very little
role and i hear that there's some and
they don't have anything that you would
call theater it's just some it's not the
human norm most human beings have
something along these lines i bet they
have stories bigger groups
and once you have enough people you have
something that we would call performance
even if in smaller groups everybody
participates in the performance but
that's even more the same thing that
we're talking about the idea that you're
a passive audience is something that
happens particularly in the west rather
late in the game that you sit and clap
you usually people are more involved
everybody is but that is even more of
what you're talking about yeah i would
say that those things are
real and in a sense and i'm not just
trying to yank it back to woke racism to
push the book but i'm really thinking
about this my book is about people it's
actually i'm known for saying things
black people don't like black a lot of
black people aren't going to like woke
racism but what racism is going to be
hated by a lot of white people too the
woke person i'm really thinking about in
that book is a white guy
and the white guy in that case is not
somebody who i can hate because i do see
that there is a benefit that a person
gets to this religion even when it
doesn't necessarily make if we may
pardon the term sense the person can't
help it i see where they're coming from
and they frustrate me often but it
worries me that because religion
is let's let's call it for our purposes
here a different kind of reality it can
conflict with what an oppressed group
needs in order to be most comfortable
and happy in a complex society
well you okay so let's talk about that
for for a minute now one of the things
you told me earlier on was that i think
and i don't want to put words in your
mouth absolutely so if i've got this
wrong please correct me
it seemed to me that you were implying
if not outright stating that
the collectivist
ethos of much of that discourse
was interfering with your self-regard as
an individual but even more importantly
your ability to like manifest yourself
appear as and be treated as an
individual
and so we're looking we're looking here
at least to some degree for what might
constitute a reasonable uniting
principle and one of the reasons that
i've been opposing the collectivist
thought that's characteristic of the
insistence that group identity is the
primary phenomenon say socially and
cognate morally more importantly is that
it's the wrong uniting principle the
right uniting principle
is the divinity of the individual to
speak in religious terms and we can
strip that of its religious significance
and say well part of it is that the
proper level of analysis for political
discourse is the sanctit is predicated
on the sanctity of the individual
and so
we need to get serious as a culture
about whether or not we actually believe
this and and and what the relationship
between that belief and reality actually
is
so
that's hard because as you know you're
far ahead of this um far ahead of me on
this
it's hard to be an individual it's not
natural it's not i don't think it's what
we're hard wired for it's a rather new
concept and many people spontaneously
will say they want to be an individual i
think to an extent though that's fashion
and to most people group identity
is what gives them a sense of purpose
and that's the way human beings have
always been and it's hard to really make
a person realize being an individual
means that it's really just you for
example many very smart black people i
think are under the impression that
being an individual means that you have
the bravery to stick your fist up and
battle racist attitudes but the problem
is that is now a group activity that's
something that lots and lots of other
people are doing it only may seem a
little bit unusual to a very naive white
person looking on or subject to it and
so the question is how do you really
feel about these things if you want to
battle racism how would you like to do
it as opposed to adopting certain
mantras and battle cries but mantras and
battle cries are what we human beings do
we do it together that's hard that's
that's a tough thing because
individualism might not be
the way that humanity needs to go i
personally would prefer it that's my my
sense
and that's your sense i think but i
think a very coherent case could be made
that that particular conception of
marching to the beat of your own drummer
is an eccentricity that certain solitary
minded people came to cherish amidst
industrialization over a certain two or
three hundred years i don't know if i
could refute that okay so that's okay so
i think that's an extremely astute
objection let's say especially the
observation that that and you you
touched on this earlier that that
requirement for group identification is
deeply embedded in human
human the substructure of human
consciousness so let's say well we want
to have friends we want to have a family
we want to have a town or something like
that a community of 200 right embedded
in a town
i think the question isn't or the issue
isn't so much the fact that the idea
that the individual is the uniting
principle should supplant that it's that
that should be
organized underneath that in some
because it isn't it isn't an issue of
the absence of the necessity for group
identity because without that we
couldn't do anything together and
wouldn't that be a catastrophe right
yeah right right and so that has to be
recognized and i do think to give the
woke types and even if it's a religious
manifestation they're due if that does
produce a sense of cohesive group
identity then you can understand the
longing for that in a fractionated
community that in some senses got too
psychologically large so that has to be
contended with but i do really see
because i viewed the
culture wars in the university i really
believe they're battling out something
extraordinarily deep it's not it this
isn't a surface issue
part of the
debate
and this emerged out of france
the french intellectual tradition
fundamentally as far as i'm concerned is
the question of what
level of conception should be primary
and the assault on the patriarchy and on
there's more to it than that is part of
an assault on the idea of
of individuality and
and the truth that individuals hold in
their language it's an assault on all of
that it's deep deep criticism and i
think it's incredibly dangerous but i
understand why why it arose and
so definitely yeah and and i was curious
about you because you said at the
beginning that even though your mother
had taught you the in some sense these
woke precepts there was something in you
that rebelled against it
yeah it's what was that yeah it's not um
i don't rebel against the idea that for
example there is institutional racism i
don't think it should be called that but
there are inequities in society between
say black and white that are due to
racist attitudes usually in the past and
racist
biases and racist lookings past all of
those things are definitely true there
are all sorts of things in black history
that have helped to set us back that one
should certainly know about one should
know about the redlining of
neighborhoods where in many cities most
black people lived in neighborhoods
where banks would not give you a loan
all of these things are very real i
never felt like i rebelled against that
what i rebelled against was the idea
that you base your whole sense of
identity upon those things such that you
live a life that's abbreviated because
you're exaggerating how bad it still is
and you're distorting what's necessary
to create dignified lives for black
people and my feelings always been you
probably have about 80 years you know
you're lucky if you've got 80 years and
if you spend your whole life
maintaining in my time period the same
battle poses in the 80s and 90s that
people needed in the 50s and 60s after a
while you've spent your life play acting
and then you die and the world goes on
what i rejected was the exaggeration and
so for example i remember what really
there was one moment where i realized
there was something wrong with me it was
the in the wake of the rodney king trial
in 1991 and a lot of a lot of black
people i liked very much were united in
saying what happened to rodney king
shows that a black man can't get justice
in this country and i remember thinking
no
no that that statement would have made
sense in about 1965 and in many american
cities 1975 and there were islands of it
even in 1991 but the idea that as a
20-something black person you were
living in a country where you just
couldn't get justice it struck me as
beyond rhetoric especially given the
general attitude they had towards what
being black meant then as we were
standing around at stanford university a
campus where all of us had been
evaluated according to adjusted
standards out of the idea that we were
really wanted on that campus etc that we
were supposed to still be speaking that
language that the black panthers had
spoken it struck me as a pose and there
was a part of me that was deeply
disturbed by the artificiality of it and
that you were actually expected to live
it why why are the artifacts okay so you
again you use very specific words oppose
artificial as opposed to what like what
on what page like you're comparing it to
something and it it sounds it sounds
like you're comparing it and and you
don't just regard it as an exaggeration
your criticism has gone farther than
that in the past i mean you you've also
uh directly stated that
conceptualization of the problem in this
form is actually interfering with the
solutions that we still need to generate
so it's not just it it's not just an
exaggeration it's a problem in and of
itself and that's a deeper criticism so
so
so what's the artificiality as far as
you're concerned and yeah compared to
what
yeah what you're trying to live
apparently but what do you what is that
exactly
the question is how much of an obstacle
is racism after
formal segregation has been battled
after racial attitudes changed
profoundly in the 1970s and i'm just old
enough to have watched that happen just
it gets to the point where okay racism
does exist both social and institutional
but how much of an obstacle is it to
doing pragmatic things that will make
poor black people less poor and all
black people happier so quick example
would be that these days you can look at
the fact that black kids tend not to do
as well on standardized tests yes as
other kids it's there now you can look
at that and you can say well if black
kids don't do as well on the test that's
because of racism and so we need to
eliminate the test because the test
is racist now in what way is the test
racist 40 years ago maybe those tests
asked you what wine goes with chicken
that hasn't been true for generations
now so it's not about asking people
things that they have no reason to know
how is it how is it racist and there are
people today who even will imply that
black thought is somehow incompatible
with tests like that which is very close
to saying that black people are
incapable of disembodied abstract
thought and many whites
are probably identical without claiming
yeah it's it's very unfortunate
especially given that the people who are
saying it know very well the history of
that being said about black people and
so you look at the tests and you say
that because black kids don't do well on
them they are examples of systemic
racism but you have to get rid of racism
so you have to get rid of the tests
which means that you tell america that
black kids can't have their abstract
reasoning measured without it being
racist and then when you get somebody
saying well then black kids just must
not be as quick on the uptake you call
them a racist and in the meantime it's
ignored that you consider helping black
kids get better at the tests helping
black kids parents realize what free
test prep programs there are in those
neighborhoods the tests just take a
little bit of practice but you're not
supposed to talk about it because
the tests quote unquote are racist
that's a it's an abuse of language and
it's abuse of the very conception of
what racism is that's not what my mother
raised me in that's not your
grandmother's racism that's something
that comes from a way of thinking that
was
marginal in 1955 became sexy in about
1966 and here in 2021 is being treated
as impregnable wisdom someone black has
to speak out against that so that's what
i mean by the exaggeration and the
artificiality and the outright harm that
comes from these sorts of things
well and it and with regard to it being
a pose
so is it is it is it a pose of
so i could say well is it a pose of
unearned virtue i mean virtue is not
easy to earn true virtue you have to
establish let's say we'll see we see
where we go with this maybe you have to
establish a relationship with beauty and
beauty is real you have to establish a
relationship with truth and truth is
real and so to earn virtue is difficult
because beauty and truth are imposing
and and and formidable
if you have any sense at all you see
that
and so that's a daunting task to
establish genuine virtue and a
terrifying task and is the pose the
the the willingness to adopt see because
when i talked to the ideologue types and
maybe that happened most famously with
an interview i had with i think i was
just thinking about it
you mean michael eric dyson right yeah
oh i was no i wasn't thinking about
dyson i was thinking about uh gq
interviewer and that interview has been
watched like 40 million times now it's
just this ideological pose is
it is the aping of virtue as far as i
can tell and i i mean that and it's sort
of a technical sense is that you master
this language and it contains the
expressions of true virtue but you know
the kind of problems that you were
talking about and i see this on the
environmentalist side of things too
well how do you get black kids to do
better in elementary school let's say
well that's a more manageable problem
it's a problem that would take a little
bit more humility to conceptualize and
it's also a really really hard problem
and so to be virtuous
in your attempts to solve that would
require it probably require the
dedication of your entire life really to
to take a good crack at that problem
right because that's a tough problem man
and so maybe you don't want to do that
because it's
and then you're enticed and you're
enticed by your educators
into this
alternative
possibility where all you really have to
do is master a set of propositions and
you're on the winning side and that also
gives you some convenient enemies and
maybe it fulfills to some degree the
religious instinct and and it depauls me
to see the universities complicit in
this
and that they've come to see that
and i think part of that falseness and
artificiality that you
described i think the fact that that
exists is part of the
like
overbearing insistence
that the veil not be lifted and that no
one questioned this because what is
underneath it is so damn ugly yeah yeah
yeah jordan you actually
you are um
you have nailed something
i would be loath to go so near that word
virtue because the last thing i want to
do is imply that somebody isn't virtuous
nevertheless
you're getting it in that
it's an unearned virtue which people are
settling for not because they're so
callow
as to which to be virtuous without
earning their stripes but because
religion is attractive and so if you
were surrounded by people who are
brandishing this message that everything
that you don't like is racist and you
can get beyond it that way it's not that
you're lazy it's not that you're trying
to get stripes that you didn't earn but
it's comfortable because part of being
in that religion is that there's an us
versus them conception which is very
comforting you're part of a mission of
uplift which is very comforting and in a
university that religion is there it's
as if there you know people from a
church who are behind tables out in the
plaza who are waiting to recruit people
that's there as soon as you hit campus
and so
that's why so many people and now it's
not just black kids it's also white kids
fall
for this way of looking at things where
what it is is
you become virtuous without having done
the sorts of things that ideally one
might have you can your virtue signaling
and it is unearned virtue but it's
because you wish to have a cloak you're
seeking a comfort zone i can't hate
anybody for that but it does mean an
awful lot of mendacity that's the
problem
so i wasn't trying to imply too that all
objections to that process are in and of
themselves virtuous and i'm also not
trying to imply that i'm somehow
especially virtuous i'm actually quite
terrified by the proposition that virtue
virtue is something real and something
necessary and that falling short of it
is cataclysmic in some sense
existentially and so anyone who doesn't
tremble
at such a thought hasn't thought about
it very deeply and i want to have as
much sympathy as possible especially for
young people who are enticed into this
ideological identification because you
could look i was a committed socialist
when i was 16.
you know and and on intellectual grounds
i mean
talent is distributed equally amongst
the human population yet they're
inequities in society so how can that be
anything but unfair
well
fair enough it's called the answer to
that is extremely complicated but the
problem announces itself and you can
certainly see
how someone with a somewhat
compassionate bent and and even with an
intellectual bent of sorts would be
deeply attracted by the the extremely
well honed arguments that have been put
forward in favor of all those
propositions
so
or it can be even more primitive than
that i think that tribalism in and of
itself
is deeply attractive and that this is
something that can happen regardless of
intelligence level i remember in college
i wasn't a socialist but i definitely
hated republicans until i met met some
and you know i couldn't have told you
during most of the time when i was in
college what the difference between a
republican and a democrat even was i was
busy doing other things it was easier
not to know there was no internet but i
knew that those republicans who were
usually guys it was usually a few guys
with their own corner room down the hall
you didn't like them because they were
republicans and ronald reagan was bad
because he was white and he dyed his
hair or something like that that was
enough even for the smarter kids who
were smoking cigarettes out in front of
the dorm that would do
i met republicans as time went on and
realized that wait a minute i'm not one
of them but i can't see them as insane
but before that it happened i was very
happily against a whole group of people
who i knew nothing about i don't think i
was unique in that no not at all that
okay so maybe if you don't mind maybe we
could close with this because i'm
starting to get tired and i'm not going
to make much sense soon so so if
assuming i have so far so i've been
considering this proposition that that's
emerged from the woke end of the of the
of the political spectrum let's say that
all white people are racist and i think
okay
are all white people racist what's the
answer to that and the answer is
yes
and no
and
how dare you frame the question like
that that's the three answers so yes
let's look at yes first well
are all people racist
probably probably probably like we have
really really intense in-group
affiliative tendencies and yet we're
supposed to suppose that maybe
especially north american white people
can learn to not be racist unlike all
other people in the world that's a tough
proposition well all of us it's very
difficult for all of us to overcome our
in-group biases and we and we never even
want to do it completely because we want
to love our family especially and we
also only have a limited amount of time
and attention so we have to love some
people especially or do nothing at all
for anyone
so so this is a huge problem so
by stating it that way that all white
people are racist you make racism a
subcategory of white and you actually
underplay that terrible catastrophe and
significance of the problem and that's
very dangerous because we all have to
contend with this in-group preference
and our proclivity to demonize anyone we
put in the out group
and now that's a terrible tendency yeah
and that particular that question is one
of them where i depart
from what i wish were my comrades in
that are all white people racist you
know what probably to some extent the
white person who couldn't have an ounce
of racism identified in them even with
sophisticated psychological testing is
probably vanishingly rare sure and my
sense of it is when it's gotten to the
point that it has who cares
and i've often said to audiences and
i've watched some black people in
audiences having not heard this
understand what i mean if you really do
have a basic self-love then the fact
that the whites around you have various
degrees of racism really just shouldn't
matter because life consists of about a
thousand things other than whatever that
residual racism is in that white person
across the room who is you know married
to a black person and you know does all
the sorts of things that these
supposedly racist but hyper woke white
people do it's just why does it matter
so much now it's one thing for somebody
in 1925 to talk about white racism
1955-65
but today my feeling about it is with
most of the white people that a black
person who talks about that sort of
thing most knows the answer is yes most
of the white people you know are
probably very slightly racist but not in
any way that will remotely matter in
your life even including being friends
with them and sometimes close friends
why are we so obsessed with that and i
think that's a very legitimate question
life is about so much more than
obsessing over something like that
except that when you obsess over
something like that you're part of a
group it's us versus them and you have a
sense of purpose and a sense of virtue
because you're the person who's being
racist but i find that a rather feeble
way of going about
an existence with true virtue i've never
used that word so much as today it might
also indicate uh
interference with the process of coming
to terms with your own in-group
preference and tendency to deregrate
whatever out-group you happen to be
surrounded by i mean i do see this as a
terribly deep human problem you know i
presume that in the 1970s that
jane goodall found that chimps go on
raiding parties right and that that was
a major league discovery it shows how
that that
proclivity to demonize the out group is
at least six million years old right
it's deep and it's in us and so and we
all have to contend with it and so to
make now we could have an intelligent
conversation nonetheless about the
manner in which the predominance of one
ethnic group in a given society might
exacerbate those tendencies of course
but that's that's a that's something
that's certainly independent of the
notion that all white people are racist
and then you can also see that you know
it's easy to believe that progress
doesn't happen than to admit that it
happens slowly the degree to which most
white americans are racist in 2021 not
to mention white canadians from what
i've seen
is much much smaller than anybody would
have expected about 30 years ago so the
question is also just extend and yet
virtue is excellence in my mind if we're
talking about aristotle virtue is not
moral
you know moral upstandingness it's
excellence you can't be excellent you
can't live an excellent life if you're
hobbled in distorted views of what
racism is and how much it matters these
particular things will not allow you to
be the best that you can be unless you
think that the best that you can be is
somebody who is hyper articulate about
discussing bias against other people and
what a narrow topic there's so much to
do and so i just chafe against it
i think that's an excellent place to
close if you don't mind and
i really enjoyed our conversation it
flew by as far as i was concerned and i
i hope you guys for having me i hope you
have the success that you deserve with
your new book woke racism how a new
religion is betraying black america and
i i wish you well in the future and hope
perhaps that we're we meet again and
at least we're able to talk again
certainly
anything else
i think we hit it all i think i liked
ending on the virtue and the book will
be
coming out and we'll see how it does but
i'm glad that we had a chance to talk i
think that you and i are best known if
we're talked about in the same sentences
based on that exchange at aspen and i
would venture to say that although
that's really gotten around it meant
more to the audience of people who've
been watching it than it meant to either
one of us and so i'm happy to have
actually had a one-on-one with you yes
i'm very glad that that was superseded
by this
definitely thank you very much for
talking with me today i appreciate it
thank you for having me jordan and as i
said best of luck with your book and
andy in general many thanks
[Music]
[Music]
you